if you want more information there are
links in the description to videos that
have heavily inspired this one including
andrew dodson pretty much physics nima
arkhani hamid's talk and sabine
hostenfelder's wonderful and short video
on natural units i highly recommend each
of those channels slash people if you're
serious about physics
okay this video will outline how and why
to use natural units to determine a
numerical value place a numerical value
to almost any physical observable that's
macroscopic that you would like in my
opinion this should be taught first in
physics but for whatever reason there's
no single lesson there's no single
chapter in a book there's no single
lecture in a lecture series on this
instead it's strewn across
several and you start to intuit it you
start to understand it implicitly as a
physics student rather than it being
made explicit which it is being made
explicit here and that's because it can
serve you in the beginning of your
understanding of physics and even in the
middle of your misunderstanding of
physics which is where we all are
generally this video is meant to change
the way that you view physics and even
the world and that's the point the point
of view shift this perspective shift is
the point of this video while it's
outwardly about calculations it's truly
about
developing a different stance on nature
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
me my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics and i run this
channel called theories of everything
which is a podcast it's a podcast first
and foremost so don't subscribe to this
if you're not interested in the rest of
the content and the rest of the content
is about making comprehensible the
different toes that exist the different
theories of everything so for example
wolfram's theory of everything or
geometric unity that's coming up or
quantum gravity well that's the
seedlings of a toe string theory e8 etc
etc we even cover the more larger
philosophical ones because i'm
interested in consciousness what role
does that have to play with physics or
can it be derived from physics what
about free will what about god so you
can think of this as largely what is
reality okay let's contextualize the
rest of this video because much of the
misapprehension in learning comes
generally from not understanding the
context of what's being presented or
worse the context isn't given to you at
all there are time stamps here in every
one of the toe videos and they're
meticulously written so you can skip
around if you like by the end of this
you'll be able to calculate virtually
any phenomenon as well as have some
understanding of it specifically by the
end of the next let's say 60 minutes
with just high school mathematics you'll
be able to answer the following without
memorization in fact with derivation
which is superior why is there only time
so why is it that only time exists i
could have said or i could have said
only energy exists or i could have said
only seconds or only length exists i
just didn't want to come out of the gate
sounding like a buddhist by saying hey
all that exists is energy but you can
equally replace that there what is the
vacuum energy expectation i'm sure
you've heard that this is the worst
prediction in physics etc what are the
bounds on extra dimensions why saying
gravity is weak is worse than a false
statement it's meaningless statement
that deserves a bolded exclamation point
great the neutron star pressure what is
the pressure inside a neutron star by
the end of this video you'll be able to
answer that in almost a second
microtubules for consciousness we'll
delve a little bit into that that's
penrose's theory why was magnetism
understood so late that's a historical
fact but you can actually derive it from
fundamental principles we'll explain
what that means what is the size of the
earth yes you can derive the size of the
earth approximately napkin calculations
casimir pressure i'm sure you've heard
that hey if you take some plates and
then there's some mode that goes in
between there are more modes outside and
so the plates come together in a vacuum
we'll also be covering knots and quantum
gravity at least the modicum we'll also
cover the schwinger limit and salvator
pius's super force or the planck force
we'll also talk about black holes now
all these facts look like they belong
under the umbrella of physics except
perhaps maybe the consciousness one
penrose disagrees but all of them belong
to physics and disparate fields and you
would need to apply completely different
frameworks to properly understand them
that's true if you want to make a
precise calculation then yes but if what
you want is an estimate a napkin
calculation then you don't need this you
can use
natural units now this video is akin to
an introduction to the next video which
is coming out perhaps a few months from
now i don't plan on doing these
lecture type videos like i mentioned
this is a podcast channel i don't plan
on doing these much
the next video will be about how to
analyze and comprehend
a physics paper a theoretical physics
paper that lies at least currently far
beyond your current level of
understanding so i'll be going through
geometric unity and giving tips on
learning physics and mathematics in
general now let's get on to the approach
of this video so number one what's
different about this number one is that
there will be
quite a few digressions because it will
be about how to think that is how to
think about physics problems in general
rather than how to just solve certain
ones with natural units number two this
is great for theory yes but and it's
also great because it's practical the
reason is that whenever you're dealing
with numbers whenever you're dealing
with units it's akin to a choice of a
basis in the theoretical end you should
try to construct whatever you're doing
without reference to a choice of basis
much of your existence in physics so far
has taken place
with an implicit choice of a basis when
you're talking about some transpiration
let's say you say it's well it's three
meters to the left and two meters up but
then the question is well three meters
to the left from where two meters up
from where and then also what is up what
is left what are those directions per se
now the real world per se doesn't care
about your choice of coordinates doesn't
care about the chart that you choose
it's what we do in order to communicate
with others as well as it makes it
psychologically easier on ourselves but
don't confuse the coordinates with the
real world there is no detector that
detects the coordinates in theoretical
physics there's a saying that there's
nothing noble in choosing a basis true
nobility is being coordinate free number
three it will be important for us to be
precise so the reason is that otherwise
you'll be confused and you won't realize
where your confusion lies much of the
time when you're a student and you're
going to a professor or a lecturer or
your tutor
and they say well what is it that you
don't understand sometimes you don't
know where your misunderstanding is and
so it's difficult to learn a subject and
much of the time that comes from the
subject not being explained specifically
to you throughout this video i'll be
throwing out tidbits perhaps different
pieces of terminology that you don't
understand that's okay it's for those
who want to learn
slightly more and i'll also be going
through the specific steps i won't skip
a step as often as i can and that's
because i don't want you to be as
confused as myself when i was learning
much of this often steps are glossed
over because the presenter is so
familiar with them that they've
forgotten what it's like to not
understand a subject so for me when it's
delineated specifically here you go from
here to a to b to c rather than from
rather than from b to d let's say then
because the logical progression is made
painstakingly clear you understand it
better for example we will not be using
this symbol what the heck is this
what the heck
is
this
now that deserves a
bolded
exclamation point the reason is that
well is zero approximately one
is
one approximately ten ask the person
who's teaching you please define this
guy specifically what the heck is that
this is not a mathematically
well-defined symbol this quote-unquote
approximately symbol so instead what
we'll use is this
which means on the order of so 10 is on
the order of 90. they have the same
amount of digits 102 is on the same
order of 999 for example in the interest
of being precise technically this video
should be titled how to approximately
solve every physics question regarding
observables but that's unwieldy and
doesn't fit the title character count
number four is will be s chewing
exercises in favor of a point of view
shift now generally when i watch videos
online they're generally given by
lecturers to university students and
then they say okay we'll leave this as
an exercise to you if you want to learn
more do this as an exercise however even
highly highly motivated people don't do
those exercises generally you're trying
to get an overview and the lecturer is
used to assigning problems to students
so they think that the viewer is going
to actually do them but they don't and
it's tedious and so what's more
nourishing is to instead provide a point
of view shift so that when you're going
about your life you can convert all of
these measurements that you see to
energy for example rather than assigning
exercises which almost no one does
anyway so as chewing exercises
in favor of point of view [ __ ] firstly
it's easier to get this shift of
perspective and number two it's more
enjoyable it's fun number three it's
more practical the fifth point is that
it will be extremely lean and what i
mean by that is that there will be
little fat there will be little that's
extraneous this is meant to be a video
that you can watch you can re-watch not
only when you've
forgotten about natural units and you
want to
get some understanding get some handle
on how to calculate with them do napkin
calculations but also
when you've lost some motivation to
learn mathematics or physics there will
be myriad points throughout about
how to think about mathematics and
physics in terms of a general approach
to learning like i mentioned before this
latter point will be expanded upon in
some video that i'll release in a few
months about going through a physics
paper that you currently don't
understand some theoretical physics one
and i believe i'll be doing geometric
unity number six now this one's more for
you
if you don't understand
a part of this video that's fine keep
pushing this comes from wheeler the
point is not to drink from the fire hose
that's what we think we're supposed to
do but instead you're simply supposed to
get
wet
same with watching the podcasts on this
channel sometimes they're extremely
technical people say well i i can't
understand so and so that's fine just
keep watching the first passage is
generally to just know where are you
going so that you can contextualize the
understanding that comes earlier much of
the time we're told look physics and
mathematics you build upon it and you
have to know the foundations otherwise
the top will be shaky and that's true
but it's
it's often useful to keep going even
when you don't understand simply so that
you can know where are you going because
your misapprehension about the
fundamental steps
come from not being able to
contextualize it so it's fine keep going
don't feel like i can't drink
quote-unquote from the fire hose the
point is simply get soaked and trust
that the learning will occur
all right let's get into this what are
natural units in order to understand
what natural units are we want to know
what are units so for example what is a
meter
or
if you're being canadian a meter i'm
based in toronto if that wasn't clear
already
what is a second
what is a pound
now you'll get fairly frenzied if you
think about this for quite some time as
i have that is metaphysically what the
heck is a second what is a meter what is
length science actually doesn't answer
what is questions and this is something
that's not taught to you science isn't
materialistic science isn't
immaterialistic it's operational and
this is a point that
many people don't seem to understand
including scientists science is
metaphysically agnostic meaning that it
doesn't actually make a claim onto
ontology it doesn't tell you what is
instead science gives operational
meanings so what is a second it's
something like nine
comma one nine two comma i don't know
those three seven seven zero it's one of
those numbers you memorize as a child to
show how clever you are let's look it up
on wikipedia
so let's do this wikipedia a second
it says here the second is equal to the
duration of nine one nine two six three
one that's what i've forgot six three
one seven seven zero periods of the
radiation corresponding to the
transition between hyperfine levels of
the unperturbed ground state of a cysum
atom a certain isotope of a cesium atom
okay so then the natural question that
comes up is why
this
number
so why this and not some other number
and the reason is because in london many
decades ago someone in some back alley
took methamphetamine on a tuesday night
and came up with that number now i'm not
kidding it may as well be that to
someone studying high energy physics in
the same way that
well what the heck is a kilogram what is
a kilogram
it means you go to
paris you go outside paris actually so
on the borders of paris you go to some
vault
and you deal with people being
condescending to you because you don't
speak english then you duplicate this
little metal slab that's in paris you
duplicate it 67 times
so that you have 68 of them in total
i'm just being quick with my writing 68
of them is in total then you measure
yourself on a scale
and these two numbers will coincide
that's what it means it's an operational
definition now physicists like to use
units that appear in nature so units
that appear
and those we call natural
units
now there is some
at least with me there's some
controversy with what's considered
natural because when someone comes to
you with a
some dish and they say this is a natural
dish and that's unnatural well what do
you mean that that those doritos that
are unnatural did they come from outside
this universe from some void because
isn't everything in this universe
natural aren't we a product of nature
and so what we create is natural
okay what a physicist means by natural
is that it's invariant across the
universe as far as we can tell to be
extremely precise what we mean when we
say natural units natural in the natural
units is natural with respect to our
current understanding in order to make
certain equations simpler and remove
arbitrary human qualities
why do i say arbitrary human qualities
and not just human qualities well in
some sense even an electron is a human
construct in the sense that it's there
because it
nature doesn't parse itself out into
these elements i mean you can say
elementary elementary seems to be an
objective quality because of the way
that we define what an elementary
particle is it's an irreducible
representation of something so the fact
that it's irreducible means if it could
be reduced in this block matrix form
then we can just decompose it and we'd
say those elements are elementary but
the reason why we set aside some special
canonical place for the electron is
because it's useful for us it makes
our models easier to understand simpler
outcomes razor etcetera there's plenty
of philosophy that undergirds natural
again this is not usually explained and
you'll be led astray if you don't
understand that point now here's another
point that's ordinarily not explained
observables
have
no
units
they're
dimensionless
let's say slash ratios
okay now what's meant by that again when
you say that you weigh 68 kilograms it
means you take 68 of some other
reference
quantity some other reference object and
then you stack 68 of them and then then
you get yourself it's actually 68 it's
not 68
kilograms per se
you can also think of this in another
way if you wanted to speak to aliens
which by the way is another topic on
this channel not speaking to aliens per
se but ufos then it would be foolish to
say i weigh 68 of some
product from france now you can reverse
this and imagine an alien is speaking to
you and you say well how much does your
craft weigh and they say oh it weighs
four gar bars and then you're like what
the heck is a garbar then they say well
that's how much
liquid we release from our bourbons
every two farkles it doesn't provide
much information so instead we do what
you see colloquially which is c equals h
bar equals one okay let's get to some
myths about natural units before
exploring exactly what that means so
firstly one of the myths is that we just
simply set
c to equal one to equal h bar this is a
meaningless statement as it's written
and the reason is it doesn't they can't
equal one it means we're now using
the speed of light and h-bar as a
reference for some other quantity that
we're trying to develop if you're
confused about this now then that means
you're thinking about this correctly
because it's not ordinarily explained
it's left ambiguous
let's look at this let's imagine what is
the speed of let's say some car on the
highway
so the speed of a car on a highway
equals we would say 100
kilometers
per
hour
these are the units
and that's the magnitude with respect to
those units so if i wanted to say what
is the speed
sorry that's already speed what is the
speed of light
what we mean is two nine nine seven nine
two four five eight again it's one of
those numbers you try to show how clever
you are when you're a child by
memorizing meters per second
now look this is actually what c is c
refers to all of this c doesn't just
refer to the magnitude c refers to the
entirety of it including the units so
when someone says c equals one c equals
one what they actually mean is that we
are now using units where we've taken
that two nine nine seven nine two four
five eight meters per second and we've
placed it in here so we've taken this
guy and we've placed it in here see all
of this is not ordinarily explained and
it's because
as an undergraduate you're especially
used to writing with reference to a
coordinate basis which is why i said try
to do everything you can coordinate free
if you have an instructor you're lucky
enough to have an instructor you always
ask how can you represent these
equations coordinate free another way of
thinking about this is that you we have
graphs in physics and math constantly
plot and those etchings are akin to
choosing a unit the fact that we put
lines with etchings means we've chosen a
coordinate so these etchings outward are
it implicitly a choice of coordinates
but nature but if you look again like i
mentioned there's no detector that can
detect the coordinates much like if you
take a picture with your phone and you
then look at it on the screen and you
zoom in you see pixels the pixels are an
artifact of you taking a picture and
trying to manipulate it in some manner
the world itself is not pixelated unless
you're to believe thomas campbell or
donald hoffman another reason to think
coordinate free is you'll start to
construct constructions that actually
depend on your coordinates when they in
fact don't in nature and then you wonder
why are you getting an incorrect answer
so for example in physics and so on we
often use
let's say
this
and then we represent it in some
symmetry this is how theoretical
physicists generally reference matrices
they don't like them so they call them
symmetries these rows and columns but
then you also would reference this same
object
with numbers in a similar manner
however they transform completely
differently so one is an endomorphism
and then the other is a two form or a
bilinear form and they transform
completely differently and which is why
you have transpose which is it's not an
ill-defined object but it's a strangely
defined object the inverse of a matrix
is more
copacetic but the
transpose is a strange one
so this one is a two form a bilinear
form the metric in the s
with in einstein equations is a two form
it's a bilinear form and also the
determinants of endomorphism is a
completely different object it's
invariant compared to the determinant of
a two form or a bilinear form and then
as you start to understand this
coordinate free you'll realize that
there's a special place in hell for the
person who developed the transpose it's
an unwieldy object another one that will
confuse you if you think in terms of
coordinates is that the wave function
you ordinarily think of the wave
function as going from some rd or some
subset of rd
two
to the
complex numbers but actually this guy is
a section
on a c
line bundle and you need to understand
bundles in order to understand it
coordinate free so that you can do not
only polar coordinates and you wonder
why the heck does the derivative change
well that makes sense when you
understand it in terms of a principal
bundle and then the associated bundle
but also in terms of no longer staying
in rd what if you want to move to a
curved space for quantum mechanics what
if you want to do quantum mechanics on a
curved space this is why one should try
their best to understand what the heck
is going on without reference to
coordinates and then go to coordinates
when you're actually making a
calculation so that's why this is a myth
we just simply set c to equal one to
equal h bar by the way what is h bar
well that's a bit more abstract you
don't need to understand that for the
sake of this video
but this is an ill-defined equation
there's actually a caveat here that will
come into play later another way of
thinking about it is imagine you have
one usd one us dollar
sometimes you would say it equals
127 yen it doesn't actually equal 127
yen otherwise when you have a us dollar
it would just be 127 yen what it means
is that there's something called value
or some monetary equivalent that's
another way of thinking about it
conversion what it means that you go
here with some mapping let's say m and
then here with some mapping that's
that's called let's say m prime
what it means is that you do
let's say m prime
inverse
see we have to make all these
constructions now and then that's after
you've already done m so you've gone
from here and then you go back up there
they're not the same so another way of
thinking about this is imagine you want
to change lengths instead of using
meters because you think meters are
strange for some reason you want to
measure everyone in terms of lady gaga
so you have lady gaga here which i'm
going to call
lg
so then let's say we want to measure
someone else let's say some let's say
goku so what is goku goku
equals maybe one and a half lady gagas
in length so you take half of lady gaga
and you stack that again on lady gag and
you get a goku in terms of length how
about tony robbins well that's let's say
two lady gagas now what we're doing here
is we're saying i'm going to make all my
future length measurements in terms of
lady gaga for whatever reason in the
same way that generally speaking the
prices on the internet can be made in
reference to the us dollar and then you
do some conversion to find out its
equivalent monetary value in some other
currency in the same way what we're
doing right here is we're referencing
everyone's height in terms of lady
gaga's height and it just as foolish as
it would be to say lady gaga equals one
equals the usd just as foolish as this
equation is it's tantamount to saying c
equals one equals h bar there's so much
that goes into a statement like that
that's just seeing that gives the
impression oh physicists are just
setting it equal to one so no this
statement is foolish and what's
underneath that is saying hey i'm going
to now measure everything in terms of
the speed of light so i want to measure
my car maybe it's a millionth of the
speed of light i don't know i don't want
to do the calculation right now but
let's say it's a millionth of a speed of
light so then i say well the speed of
walking let's see
is
0.00005
i'm making this up of these speed of
light units that's what it means okay so
this is all including
by the way this
right here
this is all
foolish
you have to understand what's lurking
underneath so in this example the value
is what's being referenced when i say
the real world that's what i mean is
that there's something else that's
tangible that i'm trying to represent my
quantity in reference to so from now on
we're going to no longer say that this
is moving at 500 meters per second we're
going to say that this is moving at a
fraction of the speed of light by the
way this should be a definition and that
refers to the entire object there not
just this this is just the magnitude and
that's where this is misleading because
it's just showing you the magnitude but
how the heck can c equal this in the
same way how the heck can lady gaga
equal the us
equals one that is myth number one now
myth number two is that the advantage
of
natural
units by the way it doesn't matter
whether you capitalize it or not the
advantage of natural units is that
it
makes
equations
simpler
where is the myth here the myth is one
of these words it's an article it's the
definite article the
the advantage that's one it should
actually be a advantage or an advantage
the primary advantage is that it allows
you to understand the world in a much
more elegant manner that allows you to
grasp to understand physical quantities
much more intuitively with these napkin
calculations and by the way i say napkin
calculations and not back of the
envelope calculations because when
you're outside and you're doing one of
these why where are you going to find an
envelope i don't think i've written on
an envelope or the back of one in my
entire life and then
okay so you take a napkin and you do
your calculation on it what the heck is
the front of a napkin versus the back
it's not like you choose the front or
the back or you can even tell most of
the time so it's a napkin calculation
now let's think about what did i say
over here which is that it allows you
to have only time or only energy etc etc
well there's some conversion equations
it's best to think of them in terms of
conversion just like money
these are the central equations that
allow you to convert so let's give them
a special symbol a special kind of one
number one
is e equals
you can guess this e equals m c squared
number two and then let's also make it
special
is
x
p
well now i'm going to use this
which means
on the order of so actually let's get
rid of this guy
put him on the order of there's also the
compton wavelength
which will give another
fancy symbol
which is
lambda
again i'm going to say on the order of
and
notice right now what have we done we've
already set c to equal one look i'm i'm
making the mistake notice what have we
done already we're already going to be
using units where c of light is
expressed in those units as one
so we're only making reference to c of
light to speed of light
that means that right here we can remove
that because that equals one right here
we can change that to one right here we
can change that to one and then we can
get rid of that because it's the same a
zero with order equation
is
well the speed of light equals
some
spatial amount over this
now since we're setting this to equal
one
this means that any time that you have a
distance we can express it in terms of a
speed
for example you can let's imagine that's
the earth and then we're going
to
one light year away or one light second
one light second away
i can either say hey that's two nine
nine seven nine two four five eight
meters away or i can say that's one
light second that means that it's now
converting distance into time any
distance measure that you give me i can
give you an equivalent time measure it's
not the same it's a conversion but you
can convert it to time
so this allows a conversion
of
length
to
time
and back because you can do the same
thing forward or backward and then this
one also allows a conversion
of energy
to mass
so i can tell you this is one gram or i
can give you its energy equivalent or
you can give me some energy and i can
tell you well that what makes up that
energy is the equivalent of a certain
amount of mass
now this one is also interesting because
it gives a conversion of length
to momentum
i noticed that i didn't explain where
this one comes from and it's the famous
heisenberg uncertainty equation where
you're told that the objects of space
and momentum don't commute however even
this is a misnomer since it makes no
sense to say quote-unquote objects don't
commute it should be stated precisely
that the operations with those objects
or operations on those objects don't
commute how can an object be commutative
or not without the extra structure of
the group operation again i'm being
pedantic because i was extremely
confused learning all of this and you
may be as well and it's best these
imprecise statements are made clear
clearly it's inversed and then this one
gives a conversion
of length
to mass
now how many different types of units do
we have here we have length one two time
three mass four energy five momentum and
we have four equations
which means that
we have five unknowns and four equations
which means that we can represent we
only actually have one unknown so we can
represent any of these in terms of any
quantity that we like and thus we can
represent
all of our quantities mass time length
energy in terms of one or the other
there are many reasons why a high energy
physicist just chooses energy though
they equivalently could have chosen time
could have chosen length etc it's just
for the purposes of this video and for
you to have a different point of view on
the world it's better to think in terms
of energy because of a well because of a
series of accidents the unit that they
like to use is giga electron volts gev
and that's the units we'll be using
are the units
we
will
use
so why is this useful at all why does
one want to convert to gev constantly
because if you were to give me the mass
of this in grams i don't know what that
means but if you were to give me it in
terms of gev i can tell you how many
nucleons are in here so what does that
mean firstly notice this accident again
it's perhaps an accident but perhaps not
one proton
mass
equivalent remember it's not just this
is something else that needs to be
emphasized it's not the mass of a proton
it's it's energy equivalent so once
proton masses energy equivalent is
let's say i think it's
0.938 i have to look that up
okay we go to wikipedia and we see
what is the mass of a proton so then we
look at the proton's mass and it's this
right here and that's the same as 0.93
gev if you just know what giga means
versus mega
and why is this useful at all because
it's almost equal to one
so if i want it to be sloppy i would say
equals to one but instead i will say on
the order of one gev
now we wanna know what is a gev so
firstly what is an ev
well you can look all of these up and
i'm going to be giving you these
practical steps by searching because
that's actually what it's like to do
physics or any research in general you
go to wikipedia as one of your first
sources
so it says here ev means electron volt
is a measure of an amount of kinetic
energy gained by a single electron
accelerating through an electric
potential difference of one volt
what that means is that let's imagine we
have
some potential difference here this is
one
volt
and here's an electron it's at rest
then it will accelerate a certain amount
once it gets here it will have a new
speed because the first speed was zero
it will have a new speed and associated
with that speed is an energy and then
that energy now that it has well let me
just do this it converts to energy
then the energy the kinetic energy of it
is one ev
it's one electron volt
why is this useful at all the reason is
that we have now made a connection
between one proton
one protons mass
energy let's say mass energy
equivalent
remember that's important it's not it's
energy per se it's it's
energy equivalent
we've made an association between this
and one giga electron volt and then
there's this connection which is
implicit but i'm making it explicit this
is what nema didn't emphasize the
connection isn't actually here the
connection is that this is well i'm
going to be sloppy and say approximately
because it's truly
this
the connection is that
this number one
is readily
cognitively graspable meaning that we
can chunk it it's easier for me to think
in terms of one lip balm than it is for
me to think in terms of
0.825 lip balms the reason why this
latter point well if it's not
self-evident one of the reasons why this
ladder point is important is that you'll
see in physics constantly there's an
effort to reduce some convoluted
equation into linear algebra and that's
because linear algebra is extremely
cognitively graspable it's understood
it's one of the few areas of math if not
the only area of math that's well
understood that means anytime you have a
complex equation if you can linearize it
you understand it much better in the
same way that any time we have some
complicated phenomenon we can put it to
something that's
in terms of gev means we understand it
in terms of protons
it's akin to feynman saying that the
number one lesson for some future
civilization if you had to impart one
piece of knowledge to them the best
knowledge the best bang for your buck in
terms of facts would be to tell them
that the world comprises atoms and from
that fact many other laws of nature come
now i don't know about that because to
me that would imply that you would have
some fact like let's say the atom fact
and then we have the space of all facts
and then you have to have some measure
on the space of all facts in order for
you to say that this is this one fact
implies the most facts
and that's somewhat dubious but you at
least understand informally what feynman
meant it's one of the reasons why in the
theories of everything podcast what i'm
trying to do constantly you'll see me
asking the
professor who has some extremely
intricate
baroque equation or concept i'm
frequently saying okay what does it mean
in terms of billiard balls so let's
imagine that this has a charge and this
one does too what's going on there it's
the same trying to reduce down to some
fundamentals that you understand in
order to properly understand it then
there's another
somewhat of an accident maybe it's not
heisenberg said there is isospin so that
one neutron
has similar
mass
to a
proton
and it's these that all work together
that allow
one to make use of natural units for
these napkin calculations
i'm being extremely specific and
somewhat pedantic because much of this
is glossed over and then you'll start at
least if you're like me you'll start to
be confused at a much later point and
you won't realize that some of these
fundamentals weren't explained
specifically
now let's go through a conversion chart
conversion
chart
here we go
one meter is the equivalent of
well on the order of 10 to the 16 gev
inverse ah now i haven't explained what
the inverses mean here at our equation
bolded number one and then bolded number
three we have an equivalence between
energy and mass so you say one
giga electron volt and that can mean
a certain amount of mass okay you can
convert between them but you can also
convert between the mass and then the
length but this is an inverse
relationship so that means that length
actually has inverse energy units so
anytime you give a length you can also
have given the same quantity an inverse
energy any time you have a second
you could do the same you can give that
in terms of inverse energy any time you
have a mass this one's simple you can
give it in terms of energy now this mp
is the planck
mass not the proton mass remember proton
mass is
1 gev
just for fun you can do the calculation
of a gram
and
it's this much you can do hertz which is
inverse time and by the way because
you're in inverse time you have regular
energy units which means frequency is
actually a unit of energy any time
someone gives you a frequency you can
just convert that straight to energy
we're going to be doing these by the way
i didn't actually do this but for
entropy
you can see that this is an
it's a dimensionless quantity it's
information it should be dimensionless
because it's dimensionless then from the
boltzmann constant you can get that
kelvin is also a unit of energy so
temperature is a unit of energy which
somewhat makes sense because you've
heard that temperature
is some function of the average kinetic
energy of the molecules in a room or in
a box but that statement alone isn't
enough to say that it's units of energy
because just because it's a function of
energy doesn't necessarily mean the
units of it are energy
however it does turn out to be the case
this means you can convert from energy
to temperature and vice versa all of
these are vice versa
and then one we may use later is
nanometers equals this by the way if any
of these are incorrect well then please
just write the correct one in the
comment section when you look at these
conversion charts online some of them
have a plus or minus one in the units
and that's because we're using this
symbol which means we don't actually
care too much about rounding errors
remember that this is all about napkin
calculations nz's we're just doing nc's
to be extremely concrete you can say
your desk in front of you is one meter
approximately let's say approximately
one meter long or you can give it in
terms of gev it's 10 to the 16 gev
inverses
and that means that
if you stacked stack
10 to the 16 protons
so you get proton proton proton proton
10 to the 16 times
then you get your desk so it gives you
an extremely concrete way of
understanding what your desk is your
desk is 10 to the 16 protons stacked one
after the other and by the way you may
say well kurt isn't gev also arbitrary
wasn't the whole point of natural units
to get away from this arbitrariness well
yes that's true except that the other
part here which is a great confluence
is that this coincides with how
engineers think engineers think in terms
of electron volts well they think in
terms of volts so now you've found a
connection between protons between
something that is cognitively graspable
between a neutron and between what you
can communicate with with others
so engineers
now throughout the rest of the video
you'll see that many different
quantities
physical macroscopic sometimes even
microscopic physical observable
quantities are expressed in terms of
these fundamental
ratios now notice i didn't say
fundamental
constants and that's because i'm trying
to emphasize the fact that they're
dimensionless
let's analyze newton's constant
and others
here's what you do in general firstly
you go to wikipedia so let's do that
right now
and you type in newton's constant so
it's also known as the gravitational
constant you've seen it before it's this
g
then we take a look at what are the
units here we go we get newtons meters
squared so on and so on so let's write
this down the units of g
and even here i noticed i made a mistake
because often you'll see online m
which means meters which means it's
actually a length
and this is a common mistake when you're
initially doing this so this is actually
mass
and this is length squared
you'll see it here that it says newtons
meter squared so length squared then a
mass squared is what it's being divided
by then you wonder well what the heck is
a newton so what we do is we go into it
because all of these are derived from
something that's much simpler usually
mass length or time so we go here and we
see that it's equal to a kilogram so
mass times length over time squared so
let's do that
okay now it's as simple as doing some
cancellations well we can remove one of
these masses we go mass
all right now we want to reduce this
even further remember there's only
length or there's only time or only
energy let's see if we can place this in
terms of only energy
we go to our conversion equations
there's a correspondence between length
and time between energy and mass between
length and momentum actually this
correspondence is between length and
inverse momentum and this is between
length and inverse mass and you can see
that just from the fact that there's a
one over and obviously that can go one
over there there's also another equation
that will come in handy
let's give it a bolded four
which is the energy time uncertainty
and this gives a correspondence between
energy
and
time
however looking at the equation you can
see that it's inverse time
that means that inverse time is energy
inverse energy is time let's now make
some substitutions
mass is the same as energy so i'm going
to call it gev time is the same as
g e v
inverse
length is the same as g e v
inverse well length is the same as mass
but mass is the same as energy so you
can make that substitution making all of
these substitutions you then get that g
the units of newtons is actually one
over g ev squared or as we'll be writing
it
simply
gev to the power of negative two
it's all simple we look and we see that
it's newtons times kilograms times
length etc actually reduces down to this
so let's underline that in red
how about entropy well entropy as we've
noted above is given by formula which
looks like
it's actually minus what i wrote before
and these are probabilities
which is dimensionless
again extremely simple now much of this
is made complicated but if you look at
it through the lens of natural units as
well as these conversion equations all
of the quantities that you know and that
you love and that you want to work with
become units of energy raised to some
integer power
how about pressure
again let's just look that up on
wikipedia that's usually the first step
it says here newtons per meter squared
that makes sense because it's newton
which is a force unit over some area and
then luckily they've decomposed it
further for us
so let's write that down that is a mass
over a length
and then we have time
squared which then becomes which we can
now do in our head but we won't do that
right now because we're trying to not
skip any steps mass becomes gev
length becomes gev inverse so it goes to
the top time is also gev inverse
so it's gev
squared and that is the same as
gev
to the fourth
this tells you an extremely important
property of pressure it's an extensive
property of space-time itself this is
one of the reasons why it's much easier
or much more useful to think in terms of
pressure rather than force because
pressure is a property of space-time
itself whereas force is some derived
quantity that usually isn't useful in
fundamental physics
now let's do a fun one how about speed
well we
think of it as length over time
and then because time and length are the
same in our conversion chart this just
becomes
dimensionless
that deserves a bolded
exclamation point
then you think well how the heck is
speed dimensionless isn't it the case
that you said over here kurt c equals
one you can't simply say c equals one
yes that's true except there was a
caveat in the caveat is that there are
these conversion equations because we're
placing it in terms of c which is
invariant it means that we can tell time
in terms of length and we can tell
length in terms of time and that means
that this equation is correct but only
when you take into account the fact that
c is invariant and these other
conversion equations
it's usually just glossed over so plenty
of preamble goes into making a statement
as seemingly simple as c equals one
equals h bar so c equals 1 is a
meaningless statement unless you're
specifying that you're using some of
these as conversions and then you're
also emphasizing the invariance of the
speed of light if the speed of light
depends on something else you can't
actually use that all of this needs to
be explained unequivocally first
it's usually not and then there's an
abundance of befuddlement that occurs
much like with the brockette notation
which looks graceful however there's
plenty of assumptions that go into it
which make it not terribly useful
let's use this to calculate a practical
quantity so how many protons are there
in you at first if you were to just say
well i weigh 70 kilograms that doesn't
give much information what we can do is
we can use our conversion chart over
here and say okay well look one gram
is this much energy so how about a
kilogram so a kilogram must be 10 to the
26 gev
using this we then get that 70 kilograms
becomes
70
times 10 to the 26 gev
which is on the order of 10 to the 28
gev
that means that what comprises you is 10
to the 28 protons and that's a much more
physically meaningful quantity now you
have some physical intuition given to
you by your weight whereas if it was
just kilograms then you have to go to
paris etc then you may wonder well kurt
don't neutrons come with protons so
shouldn't you times 2 the above yes
except because of this we're saying on
the order of so we can say there are 10
to the 28 nucleons that comprise you
protons and neutrons bound
there we go simple and powerful because
it allows these napkin calculations
let's do one that you may think requires
plenty of work but it's actually
extremely quick you can do it in a
second so what is the pressure inside a
neutron star
the pressure inside a neutron star well
firstly you have to think what is
happening there are neutrons as far as
you can see and recall that neutrons are
the same as protons in terms of their
radius and mass approximately
then as far as you can see all you see
are neutrons think about what have you
learned about a neutron star it's that
the neutrons are packed so close
together that they can't be packed any
further then you think well what is the
units of pressure and it's gev to the
fourth so we have gev times dev times
gev times gev one one one one one and we
get
pressure in a neutron star
is simply gev
to the fourth
okay that's it it's just gev to the
fourth
and this is something that you can
verify yourself if you look up what it
is in pascals and then do the conversion
and just keep in mind that some
conversion charts have a plus or minus
one on the order because sometimes
people round up sometimes people round
down now let's get through this much
more quickly because i'm re-recording
constantly there are many errors and my
facial hair is growing i've renamed this
for reasons that will become clear later
a neutron star's pressure is much more
copacetic so proportionate strength of
the forces so you know from perhaps
around high school that it's something
like the first charge times the second
charge so on and so on so on let's look
at this in terms of the electron charge
so q1 will equal q2 will equal e
v is energy we know that that's
potential energy r is inverse energy
which means this equation has
this guy here which means that this guy
here which i'll rewrite
is
dimensionless
and this is what is usually denoted as
alpha which i'm sure you've heard is one
three seven inverse
this is the reason why the strength of
the electromagnetic force or the
electromagnetic interaction is
quantifiable it's dimensionless however
if we were to look up
here notice this
this g newton
has
negative mass dimension which means that
saying that gravity is weak is actually
a meaningless statement because you need
test masses you need two test masses in
order to say that usually what's done in
fundamental physics is one takes the
most massive of all the particles the
fundamental particles and says well look
compared to the weak force which is the
weakest of all the standard model forces
the gage fields gravity is so and so
times weaker so that's what's meant
specifically by gravity is weak but all
of that needs to be stated there are
assumptions that go into that you need a
test mass and by the way this guy here
this negative square mass dimension of
the coupling of gravity plays an
extremely important role in the
non-renormalizability of gravity let's
calculate the average speed of an
electron so later we're going to
calculate the radius of an electron and
that's going to turn out to be
this but this right now just looks like
junk because we haven't derived any of
this however from this we know that one
of our equations over here
says that we can figure out the momentum
based on a length so then what is the
momentum of the average electron and
it's
and that means that this is the average
speed of an electron
and this number is the reason why
magnetism was discovered so much later
because electrons are moving relatively
slowly and we know that magnetism has to
do with the speed it has to do with
current changes thus from relatively
fundamental principles you can derive a
historic fact why was it that magnetism
was discovered much later well it's
because of this guy
and by the way you'll notice that i
spend quite a bit of time writing and
rewriting painstakingly almost and
that's because i know that clarity of
thought leads to this clarity of writing
and vice versa for myself and for you
and if you're lucky enough to have a
lecturer who's blessed in that area in
this notational refinement area then it
will translate directly to higher
comprehension for you
it's a
it's a neglected part of pedagogy i find
the logical placement of the words and
the formula matter and many of you are
trying to create your own theory of
everything you're advancing your own
you're not simply learning about others
it's one of the reasons why i try to be
specific in the podcast in general and
then also here as much as i can be given
the time constraints because generally
you're told
have truths so for example that a wave
function is a member of a square
integrable hilbert space okay but then
if you derive it is a square integrable
function necessarily square integrable
itself okay so then you limit it to
schwarz functions and then you say well
perhaps gelfon triples and so on and
then you realize well that only works
for pure states that a general quantum
mechanical state is actually an
endomorphism on a hilbert space and even
then when it's a pure state it's not a
unique
you can't assign a unique member of a
hilbert space you have to take a an
equivalence class so you generally take
them from projective hilbert spaces and
so on and the reason for me to be
extremely detailed is because many of
you are trying to advance your own toes
and if you're going to build them based
on some shaky foundation then you're
going to derive
fantastic formula and fantastic theories
based on
half truths and based on what's
misleading you can it's akin to dividing
by zero you can prove the entire
universe from scratch if you divide by
zero what i found is that the
popularizers of science have generally
spent a significant amount of time on
let's say the wave particle duality
instead of telling you it's a quantum
mechanical object that behaves in this
manner well mainly
for for a few reasons and one of the
reasons is because they want to evoke
awe in you and show you how unimaginably
intelligent these
esoteric physicists are for being able
to grapple with these concepts that no
one understands well you can understand
it too if it was explained
specifically to you and then you can
search the key terms so let's say i said
the word
gelfon triple you're wondering what the
heck is that well now you can at least
look that up on wikipedia and you can
gain a far better understanding of what
a quantum mechanical object is rather
than simply saying that it's both a wave
and a particle at the same time and who
knows what the collapse means and so on
by the way i talk about this here in the
quantum gravity section of the salvator
pious interview if you want i'll leave a
link in the description this is why
quantizing gravity is so difficult and
it's explained in in some pedantic
mathematical detail mainly because then
you can see okay this is why it's so
difficult and it it's not necessarily
because you're trying to mix the jittery
with the smooth and so on like what does
that mean
let's get to knots and extra dimensions
the whole point of this is to get
familiar with the different length
scales and the different energy scales
so let's take a look at this the mass of
the pion which you can look up online is
about 10 to the minus 1 gev
the mass of the electron which i think
we've used is about 10 to the minus 3
gev thinking of physics in the manner of
natural units and gevs etc
gives you concrete ways of thinking
about some phenomenon in different
respects so for example length scales
here these automatically imply that for
example chemistry
becomes important at what scale well 10
to the 3
g e v
inverse we simply take the inverse of
this and then same with the straw and by
the way that's because the electron is
what's responsible for chemistry largely
speaking and for the strong force
we expect the scale that it becomes
relevant is 10
gev inverse and then we can simply do
our conversion over here to find out the
relevant length scale in terms of meters
let's now have a quick detour into extra
dimensions
extra spatial dimensions are called
universal extra dimensions and usually
we're dealing with one temporal time
dimension so you'll hear three plus one
or four plus one that plus one usually
means the time at some point in the toe
podcast i may do a single episode just
on extra dimensions if you're interested
let me know as well as extra temporal
dimensions what we're doing is looking
here so we're seeing that usually what
you've heard is that you compactify the
dimensions sometimes i think in the
string theory episode which i'll link
over here we talked about a collusion
compactification of 10 dimensional super
yang mills theory so that's what's being
referenced here when you hear about
occlusal klein resonance and then you
may wonder well look it says that we
have put some bounds on the extra
dimensions which is one tev but if we
take a look at what the lhc
the largest energy of the lhc is it says
here
it's 6.8 well times two so it's 13.6 tev
tev is just a thousand gev so then you
wonder well how is it that we've put a
bound of an extra dimension only at one
tev shouldn't it be at 13 tev well
strangely some of the theories of extra
dimensions have it such that the
standard model fields
stay within our three spatial dimensions
and then they leak out well gravity
mainly leaks out into another dimension
that's the add model not attention
deficit disorder but arkani hamed and
divali and then there's one more other
person and so it looks like this let's
imagine that this is a three-dimensional
slice
these are some particles and they're
moving together and then they hit and
then if a graviton is created well
graviton can somewhat come outward but
it can also leak into another dimension
and so that's one of the proposed
mechanisms to give an explanation for
why gravity is so comparatively quote
unquote weak
is that it's actually not it's somewhat
comparable it's just that it goes into
another dimension
and because we're confined here this is
where we're confined it's not as simple
as looking for an extra dimension like
you can see it just like you can see a
dna molecule
what we're looking for are deviations in
the inverse square law and this number
two here is actually
can be generalized to higher dimensions
dim
minus 2 where i'm including time here to
make this simple so for us it's 4 minus
2 which is what gives rise to this
inverse square law but if we're in
higher dimensions then we'll see a
different number here
this becomes 1 over the dimension of the
manifold that you're on minus two and in
the manifold i'm including time just to
make it simple
okay as for how we derive this don't
worry about that you can just think of
the flow through a surface if we're in
r3 then a sphere around us is like a
shell and that's a two-dimensional
surface so if you're an r3 you go one
dimension down if you're in r4 you go
one dimension down so it's r3 and so on
and so on technically to be rigorous you
need to show that the potential of some
laplacian vanishes but we can leave that
let's get to looking at some of the
papers on extra dimensions here we go so
firstly notice this this is inverse r
which is related to an energy and so
this makes sense because you know length
is inverse energy
now you're starting to get a handle on
all of this let's take a look at another
paper which i'll link in the description
this is actually a section from a book i
believe and you can take a look well
here what this is saying is that if we
have extra dimension c here is 4 plus
the extra spatial dimensions right there
that's delta you have the einstein
hilbert action this we know if we remove
this d delta y this is just the standard
action that leads to the einstein
equations and we trivially add some more
spatial dimensions right here and then
here are some matter fields you want to
couple some matter to it and notice that
it's four dimensional here whereas this
one is four plus delta and that's saying
hey let's restrict our standard model
matter field to this four-dimensional
manifold and that explains why we see
them as fairly strong but then gravity
is allowed to leak out into the extra
delta dimensions if we take a look at
this this also gives us some bounds on
the extra dimensions now there are large
extra dimensions as well the add model i
mentioned before
isn't a compactification
and you can similarly find bounds on
them which are found here now that
you're becoming more and more familiar
with tevs and gevs and so on you can at
least skim this paper and get an idea of
what's being said
notice here another number you should
recognize is the planck scale which is
10 to the 16 tev we have it written down
as 10 to the 19 gev but those are the
same numbers
now let's have a quick aside on knots if
i have enough room here what is a not a
not is an embedding of
a circle into r3 let's take an example
right there is a knot and this what
we're actually seeing this is not a knot
this is an embedding of a knot
technically these should be modded out
by isotopic equivalents i'll include a
link to a podcast where we go into more
about knots and quantum field theory
each one of these guys can directly
translate to a feynman diagram
in two plus one dimensions
now you may ask well why is it that
we're going from a circle to r3 but not
to rd well there are extensions except
you can't have s1
you cannot have s1 into r4 you can
except that every single knot can be
trivially unknotted so it can be morphed
into a circle
so that's why you'll have to have s2 if
you're going into r4 and then
s3 into r5 etc if you want to have
higher dimensional generalization of
knots but then their connection to
findment diagrams are
more complicated and i believe it's
current research
so this is only the unknot
additionally whenever you hear about the
planck length that will come up the
plank length it can't be that space is
quote unquote trivially
made up into some lattice of discrete
lattice of planck lengths planck cubed
and so on and the reason is that that
concept is not lawrence and variant
because what if you're zooming past it
then do you get smaller than the plank
length what if you make this room into
the plank length and should this room
exist from another perspective you get
into plenty of paradoxes and that's
because we don't have
an understanding as to what happens
around that scale another way that extra
dimensions can be tested is if you
collide particles so let's say they look
like this
and then
what who knows what happens here no one
actually knows their feynman diagrams
and so on but whether or not that
corresponds to something physical who
knows imagine they come out like this
well
what happened here
this is the same as this but then this
is less than this which means we have a
if they're the same particles we don't
have a conservation of momentum and then
we can say that perhaps what happened
was some of the momentum leaked into
another dimension so this is also being
looked for this is called discrepancies
and transverse momentum
now let's take a dive into penrose's
theory the microtubules of consciousness
because this is meant to be an overview
and each one of these is could be its
own two hour three hour four hour
podcast on its own at least let's simply
go to wikipedia and get familiar with
using these
conversion equations and natural units
the whole point of this video the
founders of this theory are penrose and
stuart hamerov
so if we take a look we're just looking
for equations right now we're scrolling
through i'm not concerned too much with
the background notice this this looks
extremely similar to
this
and it is it's called penrose's
indeterminacy principle much like
heisenberg's uncertainty principle what
penrose is saying is that imagine we
have one particle and then it's in a
super position so let's imagine it's a
superposition of just two states which
can be left or right let's call this
option a and let's call this option b
along with option a and option b they
have their own warping of space time so
gravity anytime you hear about a
gravitational field usually when you
hear the term gravitational field it's
the metric the space-time metric in
general relativity however
technically speaking the gravitational
field tensor is the romanian tensor and
the gravitational potential is the
metric regardless we take a look here
and we say that there are different
warpings of space time associated with
each of the options so a may have some
warping that looks like this as you go
outward and then b may look like let's
say this and then you wonder well is
this the superpositions that ordinarily
be denoted this plus this
well are we to have a superposition of
space times what penrose is saying is
that once the particles are of a
sufficient distance from one another in
metric space so over here it says eg is
the gravitational self energy and the
degree of space-time separation so the
degree of space-time separation is a bit
of a misnomer here what's meant is that
there's a symplectic measure on the
metric of space times and then from that
you assign a number to the metric of a
and then to the metric of b and you see
the difference once that difference is
large enough then there's a collapse so
this is a mechanism that merges gravity
as well as the quantum collapse as well
as consciousness so like three mysteries
in one
there's an episode with stuart hamrov if
you want to see more about that over
here it says one kilogram of an object
will reach its objective reduction
within 10 to the minus 37 seconds i
believe this is incorrect on wikipedia
because when you take a look at the
reference here
it
it actually doesn't make a
it only has one reference to kilograms
and it's 10 kilograms not one and then
it says 10 to the minus 43. so i'm
unsure where wikipedia gets their number
from and here is the better diagram that
i was trying to draw before of the
different space times
and you can see let's see yes that's
correct there is technically a
sympathetic measure on the space of four
metrics that's right and penrose is not
going into extra dimensions here okay so
let's write down that equation it's the
gravitational self energy
one over
and this is i'm saying one over because
h bar is one in our context and tau
which is the time
so let me as well just write that as t
what is the gravitational self energy
one may guess naively that it is
m1 m2 and then g over r and that would
be correct
because of this however if you look it
up online there's about a there's a
correction of about five thirds or so
that doesn't matter because we're using
this
then what i'm unclear about is that
there's still an r here so we have an
extra factor and i'm unsure of how he's
deriving
this number when there should be one
more factor to me this r should be a
function of t and this should be related
to the measure that we had here
the measure that's generated from the
metrics however i'm unsure of this and
i'm going to be speaking to stuart
hammerov at the end of the summer in
order to verify all of this an essential
feature of penrose's theory is that when
there's a wave function collapse where
it collapses to is chosen neither
randomly nor algorithmically this is
outlined in his book called the
emperor's new mind where penrose makes
an analogy between something called
non-recursively innumerable sets and
truths in mathematics that can't be
proven yet we as people as humans with
minds are able to see this as being true
by the way if you have questions about
any of this you can go to the discord or
to the subreddit people will help you
there and people will also be just as
confused as yourself and as myself and
we help one another out links to all of
those the subreddit and the discord will
be in the description
you may wonder why is it that we're
using one gev instead of
one mev because this one's the proton
and this one is the electron why are you
prioritizing the proton over the
electron well it just makes some of the
napkin calculations easier so this is
all about nc's napkin calculations as
well as it gives you a much more
concrete physical intuition later we'll
derive the radius of an atom but for now
you can see that this is the radius of a
proton it's also the energy of a proton
the mass of a proton which as we
mentioned earlier this means my desk is
10 to the 16 protons long if you take 10
to the 16 protons and stack them you get
the length of my desk and i said
desk so don't get excited okay now let's
get to vacuum energy
okay you've heard the story that the
universe is expanding and because it's
expanding it has a positive cosmological
constant and much further is expressed
to the disdain of the word prediction
the worst prediction of physics i'm sure
you've heard worst
prediction
and many people dislike this word
prediction because it's not as if a
specific theory was said to be false
because of this prediction however that
gives the impression of discounting the
calculation completely it wasn't a
prediction per se it was a comportment
namely if lambda was to
comport
with
the standard model
that is if it was to be a consequence of
absolute energy from the vacuum
fluctuations from the plank scale upward
then it should be of order let's say x
we're going to calculate that it was a
comportment test rather than a
prediction the mechanism could have been
the vacuum fluctuations of qed i believe
weinberg calculated this but it turns
out to be vastly vastly incorrect so
let's take a look there are three main
sources
of vacuum energy
and this is just from the standard model
forget about general relativity so
number one qcd and these are these
little cork bilinears number two
it's the higgs field
and number three it would be the zero
point
these are called the zero point
fluctuations
and this one is of order 10 to the minus
one
g e v
and what power goes here
it's a pressure it's dark energy it's a
property of space time itself so four
simple then what is the higgs fields
contribution
10 squared gev
and what power goes here well what else
could it be number four
let's get to the calculation of the zero
point fluctuations what this means is
that at each space-time volume space
time so now we're dealing with four not
just three volumes but i'll draw it as a
cube at each space-time volume
of length let's say l
so l
cubed in this case but actually it's
truly l4 so let's just place
l4 here okay that corresponding to this
length is some frequency omega the
reason why is that we have this relation
that energy is related to
frequency which means there's a tight
relationship between frequency and
energy you can convert between the two
we're going to do that later once we
analyze the sun
from each space-time volume of length l
there's a contribution of a certain mode
that happens within here so let's call
that frequency well whatever it's omega
in this case so we constantly get these
omegas associated with length one plus
an omega associated with length length
two
so on and so on and because of this
relation here the shorter the length
the larger the energy firstly that means
that it's infinite technically the zero
point fluctuation yields an infinite
energy but that doesn't mean that it's
literally true it means technically it's
true with our theories which already
break down
and where do they break down at the
plank scale this is what you've heard so
how about we simply cut it off at the
length scale so we let this be the
planck length which by the way is what
well it's the inverse of the planck mass
because we're taking an inverse of an
inverse we simply get that the energy
contribution
from
the
vacuum
is the plank mass to the four
and then you wonder well why am i taking
the plank mass to the four what about
these other contributions what about all
the lower order ones well remember we
only care about order and the one that
is at the top is the one where it's the
plank length so this is the only one
that meaningfully contributes this is
why this nc or this napkin calculation
which is contingent on this on the order
of symbol this tilde here is so vital
this is what allows you to do this
quickly without thinking eventually
this gives an nc of what a napkin
calculation of 10 to the 18 g e v
to the fourth
well this should be that and then that
means that this is 10 to the 72
g e v to the fourth now what is observed
what's observed is what you can get
online because this is what's calculated
by data
you'll see these strange units and then
you'll have to look up on some other
conversion site so for example let's
take a look here
here's some conversion table
you can find online they've set the
boltzmann constant to one as well
and here's another one
i'll leave these links in the
description because these can be helpful
you'll notice that some of them differ
at the last digits and the reason is
again i mentioned this some places round
up some places round down
this then becomes
10 to the minus 48 gev
to the four you may wonder why am i not
placing square brackets here well you
can it doesn't matter because you know
that this is the only unit anyway
you may wonder well where does this
observation come from like i mentioned
people look at data and then they have
some assumptions like homogeneity and an
isotropic universe and then you get the
friedman equations which you can look up
which relates the acceleration to the
cosmological constant and thus the
pressure and density
the above then yields slash implies that
our napkin calculation is the same as
the observed
times 10 to the 120
and now you know about the vacuum energy
expectation
now let's get on to calculating with the
swinger limit if you watched the
salvator pious interview you'll notice
that one coulomb of charge was brought
up so firstly let's talk about what is
one coulomb of charge let's get a handle
on it let's go to wikipedia our friend
we take a look and we see that the
elementary charge was assigned to this
exact value in 2019 so this is the exact
value of one elementary charge it turns
out that elementary charge is a
dimensionless quantity let's write this
down here
elementary charge
is on the order of 10 to the minus 19
coulombs
this means that one coulomb which i'm
going to denote as c
1 coulomb is the same as 10 to the 19
charges
so proton charges electron charges
they're the same they're just the
reverse of one another plus or minus
let's deal with protons 10 to the 19
protons that's 10 to the 19 g e v
let's get a handle on that number if we
were to stack protons one after the
other
10 to the 19 times
then going up to our conversion chart
that is
10 to the 3 meters
that's the definition of one kilometer
that means if you were to take protons
and stack them stack them stack them
without any gap in between it would be a
strip of one proton wide and then one
kilometer high
that's an extreme amount of charge great
now we've gotten out of the way what is
one coulomb let's get to the schwinger
limit
the swinger limit here it says is the
scale above which the electromagnetic
field is expected to become non-linear
so we haven't observed this because this
is an extreme amount we're going to
actually deal with what the heck does
this mean in our manageable units
the limit is typically reported as some
maximum electric field or magnetic field
before some nonlinear effects kick in
if we take a look here we see this
firstly let's just analyze this
we notice there's a c we notice there's
an h bar we set those to one that means
that all that's left over is mass over
charge charge is dimensionless mass
squared that means energy squared that
means that this is energy squared this
is a force
and then this has the same units this is
also a force so tesla has the units of
force energy squared e has this volts
over meter has the units energy squared
you can get that right now just by
looking at this for three seconds
let's just deal with e
so e is
on the order of 10 to the 18 volts per
meter this is also as defined here m e
squared c
to the three over h bar the charge of
the electron that is in our units m e so
the mass of the electron those become
one this becomes one and then we get
this
now the charge of the electron is just
one let's get a handle on this number so
firstly what is a volt we don't have to
do much work because a volt well a gev
is 10 to the nine volts and that means
so we can just take nine from inside
there and it becomes ten to the nine so
nine plus nine g e v over meters and
then we can go up stairs
to
this and see that a meter is 10 to the
16.
using our formula from above we get
that a meter is this and i will just put
some clouds around this
as well
because we have an inverse meter here we
take the inverses of this so we take one
here minus and that becomes a plus one
this then implies that we take the nine
we plus 16 to it so we get 10 to the 25
gev
squared this is by the way a unit of
force like we mentioned before
ah and those again who have watched the
salvator pius interview you know that he
mentions the super force and what the
super force is is this
it's simply the planck force
now you should have more of an intuition
as to what this actually means so this
is
one so it's one over g which is what
we've calculated before the square of
the planck mass
and you can see that makes sense in
terms of units because mass squared is
the same as energy squared is the same
as force now as i've mentioned before i
don't think force is a particularly
useful concept in fundamental physics i
think pressure is so there should be a
plank pressure
and
it turns out there is and it's called a
plank density i call it the plank
pressure it doesn't seem like anyone
else calls it that but anyway how do you
get the plank pressure well you take
some energy and you divide it by volume
what's the energy that we have we have
the mass the planck mass and we divide
it by some volume what's the volume that
we have we have the planck length and we
just cube that
and that's how you derive the planck
pressure at least that's what i think it
should be called now at first i was
going to draw some picture to give some
interesting ideas to what the schwinger
limit is in some fundamental manner but
actually force isn't
a particularly interesting concept
because it requires extra structure so
for example we know that we have these
inverse squared laws that characterize
the coulomb force and gravity
which technically means that you can get
however
large of a force you'd like depending on
how close you are to the original source
to the point source if it's a point
source this to me demonstrates a flaw
in newtonian mechanics from the get-go
and yet it works so well thus if a
particular theory has a major flaw
perhaps give it a chance to breathe
before dismissing it as patently broken
see all of this is decidedly simple and
often you'll be confused but not know
where your confusion is often what will
happen is you'll ask someone to explain
or re-explain some phenomenon or some
mathematical trick and then they'll say
well what part of it did you not
understand and you won't be able to give
an account because your confusion is
such that you're unable to see where
your confusion is that is to say you
don't know the aspects of the technique
or the mathematical trick or formula or
structure etc that you don't understand
so asking someone to explain a
particular part because you've just
chosen some part and you say i don't
understand this somewhat fruitless
because that was
arbitrarily chosen by you this is one of
the reasons why it's great to read from
multiple sources so watch multiple
videos on the same phenomenon the same
trick the same formula you'll see
professors when they're being
interviewed or when you go to their
office they'll often have
a plethora of books and then you think
well they're extremely bright and they
are they're extremely extremely
extremely bright hard-working people but
then you wonder why do you have five
books on linear algebra and it's because
even ed whitson needs to read from
multiple sources on the same topic in
order to truly understand it you need to
see it from multiple perspectives
actually i spoke to jordan peterson
about this exact topic i'll leave the
podcast in the description so if you
feel like some concept is far beyond you
perhaps it's not perhaps you need to
re-watch the video so you can re-watch
this one if you like or you can watch
from multiple sources and then it will
slowly start to make sense you'll start
to see this baroque intricate complex
object from multiple perspectives you
can only see a projection of it and then
you start to build a shape of it seeing
it from one source generally doesn't
help to sum up learn from multiple
sources read multiple sources watch
multiple sources sometimes you don't
need to know where your confusion is
because at least you don't consciously
need to know because it will
unconsciously resolve itself after
learning from different perspectives
okay now let's get to number eight which
is annihilating positron electron pairs
and quantum gravity we got to get
through this quick i'm likely going to
turn this screen off i'm making way too
many mistakes i'm recording this over
and over and different parts aren't
working so
if there are any errors here obviously
leave them in the comments it's great if
you unceremoniously point them out i
don't mind i'll highlight them
annihilating pairs of positron electrons
and quantum gravity so firstly what
happens when you look at the vacuum
simply look
well we know this relation which is e is
the inverse of time
and let's imagine that we wanted to
create particles that were on the order
of an electron so electron positron then
we just replace this e with the mass of
an electron technically it's two but it
doesn't matter because we're saying this
is on the order of
this means that for a small amount of
time
an electron positron pair can be created
and then you can also ask this is a unit
of length which means that if you were
to probe the vacuum if you were to look
close enough and exactly how close
enough well what is me me remember it's
akin to 1mev which is the same as 10 to
the minus 3 gev
this means looking at empty space itself
if you look close enough just the act of
looking close enough will create the
electron positron pairs now this is
something you know from quantum field
theory and by the way when people say
quantum field theory there's not the
quantum field theory there are multiple
it's it's more like a framework so
there's five four and then there are
different well string theory itself can
be thought of as a generalization of
quantum field theory so when people say
quantum field theory you should ask them
well which quantum field theory are you
referring to now let's talk about
quantum gravity forget about field
theory when it comes to quantum gravity
there are several conceptual infinities
that pop up so for example
so firstly if you're going to be
infinitely accurate about let's say
where an electron is you have to measure
it an infinite amount of time or prepare
something and then measure that in
infinite amount of time because there's
an error an uncertainty associated with
the measurement and then another
infinity comes in when you're having to
store all of those bits somewhere and
then you also need to make your
apparatus size infinitely large because
you want to make sure that there's no
quantum fluctuations that make an error
in one of your bits as well as well
decoherence etc so there are many
antinomies that crop up which imply that
however we're ordinarily viewing our
laws or viewing space-time it must be
some approximation
also interestingly enough when it comes
to higher energies it doesn't mean lower
distances when it comes to quantum
gravity ordinarily we think well you
just place in plenty of energy to probe
a smaller and smaller distance well
that's true except at some point you
create a black hole
that is to say if you want to measure a
small distance while you put in more
energy but if you want to measure an
even smaller distance you put in more
energy at some point you just create a
black hole and then the more energy you
put in the larger the radius of the
black hole so at some point larger
energy actually means larger distance
and then even more fundamental than that
the black hole will start to evaporate
and let out hawking radiation which is
low energy particles even though what
you inputted was high energy particles
so you get a strange intermingling of
high and low and the reversal of it from
what you'd expect from our ordinary
calculations okay now let's talk about
black holes so how much density is
required to create a black hole turns
out that's an ill-defined question
because we need to pick a test mass much
like with gravity and the coupling
constant it's dependent upon mass same
with black holes you can get whatever
density you like so let's just choose a
mass and then ask a different question
how small of a region what is the radius
called the schwarzschild radius what is
the radius that we can take this mass
and squeeze it into such that it will
produce a black hole i'm going to call
this schwarzschild radius capital r and
first we need to choose a mass so let's
choose a copacetic one perhaps the
planck mass and then think well what
region of space how small do we have to
squeeze the planck mass to create a
black hole we'll do this in a variety of
ways number one naively it's simple the
standard physics folklore says what we
do is we take a plank mass and we stuff
it into a plank length and that creates
a black hole then we wonder well what is
a plank length what's a plank length but
an inverse planck mass
so let's say
planck length
is
inverse planck mass we've used this
answer many times and we're done that's
the answer in one line we've derived the
schwarzschild radius of a mass flank of
a planck mass another way of calculating
this again this is also naive is to
think okay what does it involve it
involves gravity so newton's constant
and it involves some mass let's give it
a variable name for now mu so it
involves g and it involves mu
which is a mass
we then use these quantities to come up
with a radius which is length now how do
we combine g and mu so newton and a mass
to make the units match up well it's as
simple as
combining it in this manner because
recall this is of units inverse mass
squared and this is of unit's mass and
so we have an inverse mass in total and
this is an inverse mass unit as well
keep in mind that there are no alphas
here and the reason is that we're not
referencing electric charge at all
now we know that g
is
mass planck squared inverse
and we know that we can set mu in this
case to be mass planck and then we
recover
same formula let's do another naive
calculation what would the density of
such a black hole be we know that it
only involves the planck mass and we
know the units of density and so we
would imagine that the density would be
mass length to the fourth and that's
actually correct
and then for a final way of calculating
this we go to wikipedia
what is the schwarzschild radius and we
see that it is
r
2
g m
over c squared now for us
this 2 drops out because of this symbol
here this on the order of symbol the c
becomes 1 and we then recover g m
which you'll notice is the exact same as
this formula that we have here except we
just called it mu and they called it
capital m
note one needs to be a bit prudent here
because the volume inside a horizon is
dependent on the coordinate system and
so the densities are also dependent on
the observer
if you don't have a lesson on this then
it will appear as if this is magic or
that it requires years and years of
training but it's not either of those
two the popularizers of science have an
incentive to mystify
these subjects for you unless you're in
the
universities however it's fairly
effortless if it's explained
by belaboring these technical details
and being extremely precise now you may
also say hey kurt well i could have come
up with any first attempt at a formula g
to the power of 5 and m to the power of
2 and so on and so on
or square root of so on and so on and
yes that's correct which is why it
requires a certain amount of physical
intuition as well however in this case
the dimensional analysis would make all
of this trivial because you have to have
inverse square mass as the left and the
right side dimension anyway the left
hand side of the radius the short style
radius which is a length has to match
with whatever the units are on the right
hand side which severely limits the
amount of formulas you can generate
also keep in mind that some of these
formula depend on the fact that we're in
fairly low dimensions wherein
let's say dim of our manifold is four
well it's
three plus one so that's space
that's when we're calculating the
density of a neutron star and we said
hey what we do is we look to our left
look up look down look look toward and
backward and all we see are neutrons and
thus we get
gev
to the fourth this actually depends on
sphere packing because the atoms act
like spheres and in higher dimensions
this doesn't work because
spheres don't act like cubes in higher
dimensions they become less and less of
the space and thus over here we're
drastically overestimating or
underestimating our quantity and this by
the way is assuming flat space if we're
in hyperbolic space well then it becomes
even different there's no limit to the
amount of spheres that can surround
another sphere and the concept of
average quote-unquote density becomes
more difficult to define accurately
now one of the reasons for being this
captchas or let's say scrupulous let's
say over scrupulous is because
there are enthymemes what are called
enthemines which are unstated data
unstated assumptions that go into an
argument and the reason they're unstated
is because they're so simple they're so
familiar many people like even nema
arkani ahmed don't go through each of
these assumptions one it would just take
too long but two is that they're so
familiar they are generally glossed over
but i like to make as much of what's
ordinarily below the earth i'd like to
unearth it because then perhaps you
won't be as confused as myself when i
was learning these subjects if you'd
like to learn a little bit more about
enthymemes some example of them in
physics then you can check out this clip
with luis elisondo linked in the
description okay so that was a quick
detour into quantum gravity if you want
to learn more like i mentioned there's
an extremely detailed episode on quantum
gravity
with salvator pious and that's linked in
the description now we should get on to
the sponsor message just so you know
anytime there's a sponsor message on the
tow channel there's usually a
timestamp here that says click on this
timestamp which somewhere here as well
as in the description because i don't
want to manipulate anyone into watching
a sponsor message that generally means
because this channel depends on the
patrons which we'll talk about and the
sponsors that's the only reason i'm able
to do this full time it usually means
that the sponsors pay less because
people will just click on the timestamp
however i'm hoping and i well i hope
this is the case that in the long run
the trust that's built between myself
and you by saying you're not being
manipulated into a sponsor message you
can always click out of them and the
sponsors hopefully it's better for
everyone the sponsors myself and the
audience in the long run now the sponsor
for today is brilliant brilliant.org
toe is where you can visit if you want
to get 20 off an annual subscription
what brilliant is that it's a website
where you can go and you can take
courses and they don't feel like courses
it makes learning math and science and
engineering an extremely practical fun
enterprise where it's interactive rather
than you being told information you can
play with the information and speaking
of information in a little while from
now i hope to speak to chiara marletto
or david deutsch on constructor theory
and that's heavily based in information
theory so i decided to take a course on
information theory and
from that you find that this formula
which i keep referencing over and over
this formula is an extremely natural
formula for entropy and it would be
strange to define it in any other manner
again visit brilliant.org tow to get 20
off your annual subscription the second
sponsor is algo and algo is an
end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company with software that
helps business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stock outs
reduce returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by amjad hussein
you can support the tow podcast as well
as your own learning by visiting
brilliant.org toe and also by visiting
amjad algo.com all the links are in the
description you should also know that
it's the patrons as well that allow this
to happen i was supposed to spend about
two hours on a video like this it's been
almost two weeks at this point because
of different errors and so on but i'm
able to do this because of the patrons
so if you want to support content like
this then please do consider going to
patreon.com my wife is also extremely
thankful too as now she's full time with
me responding to the community and
helping me plan the direction of toe and
she's extremely extremely grateful every
time we get a new patron she's like oh
my gosh that's so sweet so both my wife
and myself thank you so much okay let's
get back to these nc's these napkin
calculations with one about the length
of an atom the radius of an atom we'll
start to move quick from this point
let's determine the bohr radius
we have a model here with the electron
on the outside and then the proton in
the center so how do we determine the
radius of an atom
let's call that ra
firstly what do we know the energy
has a contribution that looks like this
this is what we've derived earlier
and we have another contribution
which comes from the kinetic term
and this we can use equation number two
the bolded number two
to change this p square
into an r squared
which mass is this this is the mass of
an electron
and for our purposes we can get rid of
these
factors here and just say well what
minimizes this
the graph of this looks like
this and then there's a minimum point
and then it starts to look like
1 over
r in the long run yes it looks like 1
over r and then in the short run it
looks like this guy over here
we want to know what is the minimum
point right here
you can differentiate this to get the
answer or you can guess and then you get
that
the star equation implies
this is the bohr radius and we were able
to derive that in maybe two or three
lines with napkin calculations we can go
back over here where i should have said
this was the radius of an atom
and now we get that from equation number
star
and by the way because this is the
average speed of the electron of the
atom this is the reason why
schrodinger's equation works because
schrodinger's equation is
non-relativistic and you can see that
just from the factor alpha which means
schrodinger got lucky
let's skip forward because we're going
to need this for our next napkin
calculation i realized that the size of
the earth comes first how would we go
about calculating the size of the earth
well that occurs when the gravitational
pressure
is counter balanced by the atomic
pressure so this is unlike the neutron
star it requires a bit more work so what
is the gravitational pressure let's call
it capital p and it's going to be some
energy over some volume what energy well
the gravitational energy sum m we don't
know what m yet we'll figure this out
over r and then over some volume so
r cubed
however
recall
that
g g newton so the gravitational constant
is the planck mass squared inverse and
also let's make a density so a density
is what it's some mass over some volume
which is let's say mass over r cubed
then these two
combine to help make this
and
that is from one and two which go into
this
now we would like to know what the
atomic pressure is so this atomic
pressure which i should denote these
differently let's say
the pressure due to gravity and the
pressure due to the atoms this atomic
pressure is going to be again some
energy over some volume so what is the
energy well it's going to be the energy
associated with the atom which we have
over here so let's call this e a
e a and this is going to be over r a
to the third
after substituting we get
then we want to know well what is this
density here this rho this rho is going
to be some mass
over some
volume because that's what a density is
and what mass well a proton mass
over what volume
making in substitutions we get one over
the planck mass this is different i
should have used different notation but
this is the proton mass this is the
planck mass
squared
alpha sixth
m proton
squared
of the electron
and then r squared
and this implies that the radius of the
earth
this implies that the radius of the
earth is this
so this is in general for rocky planets
now this means that alpha factors in the
mass of the electron the planck mass fat
while g factors in the mass of the
proton all of this comes into play to
derive the size of the earth or the size
of rocky planets in general like mars
and venus and so on this is what's
extremely powerful about this napkin
calculation technique and natural units
etc this was perhaps six or seven lines
of derivation that you do in a closet to
figure out the radius of the earth
by the way for fun if you want to
calculate what is the weight of the
world you can do so in a second so we
have some guy
here
and he
is some angry fellow so let's make him
angry
and let's just make the rest of his body
a stick figure
and he's holding the world
well what is the weight of the world the
weight of the world not the mass of the
world well you can get the mass from
this but the weight of the world is
actually zero so when you hear that and
the reason is because it's all pointing
toward the center you're experiencing
the weight of the world actually the
weight of the world if you want to be
atlas you just do a handstand because
the weight of the world is well it's
technically zero because it's pointing
from every single direction zero now the
reason why i say technically zero is
because then you may say well okay let's
imagine that we're here on earth so we
want the gravitational force of the
earth to hold up another gravitational
force well let's say you place some mass
here yes it's heavy let's say you
increase it you increase it you increase
it to the size of another earth then
actually the weight is zero because
you're in the in between points of the
same masses so in some sense the weight
of the world is
fairly manageable
all right now let's get to cutting a
solid now by the way i left out some
factors here which i've corrected here
and the reason it's written in this
manner is because you can then relate
the size of the earth to the size of an
atom and the fact that gravity is quote
unquote weak is what plays into the
largeness of a planet or the smallness
of a planet as for cutting a solid
what we want is just this equation
all we have to do
is exceed the atomic pressure all we
have to do is just place what is greater
than this equation there we go extremely
extremely simple notice this this is the
most important aspect of this video is
that there's a perspective shift you can
now carry this around with you and do
napkin calculations nc's you can even
leave them in the comments and derive
what ordinarily you would think you
would need nuclear physics or special
relativity by the way about special
relativity many people talk about time
dilation and so on but to me what's most
interesting about special relativity is
that it messes with what you think
existence is it places you in an
unhinged manner so let's take a look
over here if there's some
event that occurs outside your light
cone then what's considered simultaneous
is a dubious concept the reason being
that if you were to say for example the
corner store the store on your corner
doesn't exist anymore well why are you
saying that it's because now it is no
longer there it is now
bought by someone else or it is now
demolished
well there exists another perspective
where it does exist this is explored in
the carla ravelli interview and this is
because the notion of simultaneity is
placed on an unassured grounding
let's get to a laconic derivation of the
casimir falloff so all you need to know
about it is what you've heard from
popular science which is that it's a
demonstration of the vacuum fluctuations
because there are certain modes that are
allowed and not allowed in between the
plates there are more outside than
inside and thus they come together
you know that it's a pressure and we
have that it falls off as some r to the
n what is the n what could it be but
pressure so it's r to the fourth there
we go we get that the casimir pressure
falls off and it's a minus because it's
an attractive force
as one over r to the fourth ordinarily
this is an extremely tedious calculation
we can go to wikipedia right now just to
check
you can see from wikipedia that it
requires quantum field theory and you go
through plenty and plenty of rigmarole
just to arrive at this which is the a to
the fourth minus that we were referring
to these factors are what we firstly
these are set to one this is what we
didn't derive but you were able to get
an estimate now you may wonder why is it
that we go through so much pedantic
palaver just to arrive at a small
correction when we could have done this
in one laconic line
the reason is that sometimes often you
want to be precise for example you don't
want a surgeon that approximately
operates on you
thus in mathematics one goes through
great pains to make explicit each axiom
and line of reasoning now there are
other reasons for being axiomatic and
specific for example you may wonder why
does it take 100 pages to arrive at one
plus one equals two so there are a
couple reasons so one of the reasons is
that we don't derive that one plus one
equals two we validate the axiomatic
system by seeing one plus one equals two
as a valid target and knowing we need to
hit it seeing we hit it validates the
axiomatic system that produced it number
two is because now that we have axioms
and then we show that something is
constructed in this manner because we've
set it to be then that means that we can
set it differently we could have
constructed it differently so for
example setting the curvature to zero
gives euclidean geometry and then we
wonder well what happens if we don't set
it to zero then we get more general
spaces like non-euclidean geometry which
as you know has a crucial role to play
in general relativity
all right now let's get to analyzing the
sun this one is a simple one we firstly
go to
our friend google and we search for the
sunlight spectrum and we see it looks
something like this
and we see okay this peaks approximately
at let's say 500 so it's 500
nanometers is the wavelength we then go
to our conversion charts
and we see okay we can use equation
number three
and we're going to use
equation number three and we're going to
use this and we're going to use this
to get a temperature
this gives a temperature on the order of
5000 or so well let's say on the order
of
it's about 5000 kelvin if you want to
work it out specifically or you can
simply say it's on the order of so and
and we can search what is the
temperature of the sun and we see that
it's approximately correct
where i just round it up here so it
could be between 10 to the 3 10 to the
4. it's actually
halfway in between
by the way it's from this fact that you
can look at leds that come from your
lights or your cell phone screen and
determine what temperature it would have
if it were a black body radiator and
note that your cell phone isn't
thousands of degrees hot thus allowing
you to infer just from a napkin
calculation that leds that characterize
your phone screen don't produce light as
black body radiators in the same way
that for example incandescents do
now let's intuit the radius of the
electron as you know the radius of the
electron is well it's a point particle
however let's think about it classically
so here's how lorentz and others thought
about it classically we have this
electron here let's call it e
and it's emitting some electric field
here what we want is that the energy of
the electron so
alpha over r e which we have before so
the energy of the electron
we don't want that to be much greater
than m c squared of the electron so in
our units m c squared is just m
which implies that r e
is simply this
and there we go we have a classical
derivation of the radius of the electron
turns out that
and by the way lawrence and others
thought that okay the classical laws
have to break down somewhat here
something strange has to occur at that
radius it and they were trying to
analyze it and they didn't get the right
answers and that's because quantum
mechanics comes in and they had no idea
about quantum mechanics which says
actually around the electron is positron
electron pairs and so on and so it's
cloudy and the radius of this if we go
in here the radius of one of these what
is it what do you think it may be well
it's an electron positron pair so it's
this much well it's two of that but it
doesn't matter the point is that the law
started breaking down at a distance 137
times greater than where they thought it
would have broken down if we extrapolate
this line of reasoning to our current
models that is the standard model and
general relativity while they suggest
that there's some breakdown that occurs
at the planck scale my money would be
that new laws would be required far
before we get to the plank scale maybe
not 130 times before the planck scale
but many many more orders of magnitude
prior to that energy
all right now we're on to solids and
x-rays if we want to find out the number
density that is the number of atoms in a
solid per unit volume what does it look
like well number
density
firstly let's think about the units
it's gev to sum n what is n
is it minus three it's plus three
and what information do we have we have
the radius of the atom and so it's that
cubed and we can use this equation from
before
alpha times the mass of the electron is
the radius which means we have
which is kev to the third and this is
one of the reasons why it's much better
to work with gevs and so on because this
gives you an actual
tangible amount do you understand what a
kev is and by the way kev what is its
relationship to light
that is to say if we're on the order of
a length that is
let's say just one kev then we'll need
to shine a light
whose wavelength is at least one kev in
order to resolve this distance i'll
explain exactly what that means to
resolve it and then you can wonder well
what is one kev of light you can look
that up online let's do that right now
so you can see from this napkin
calculation that an x-ray is what allows
you to probe solids that's why we use
x-rays because their wavelength is just
short enough to resolve the distance of
the atoms within a solid and when we
talk about a certain wavelength is
what's needed to resolve a certain
distance that was never explained at
least not to me properly i always heard
of it in terms of balls you take some
large ball and you try and throw it and
you try and resolve you need smaller and
smaller balls in order to get higher
resolution but i think a better way of
understanding this understanding why we
need x-rays or whatever uv rays whatever
the light is to resolve a certain
distance i think it's better explained
like this
if we zoom in here so let's zoom in this
is
let's see how many pixels wide maybe
this is
one two three maybe this is on the order
of 50. who knows but then if i say let's
pixelate this let's put it in a mosaic
see if we make this cell size the cell
size by the way is equivalent to a
wavelength so we want the wavelength
small in order to resolve
shorter and shorter distances
if we make the cell size fairly large
like 200 then we can just make out that
there exists some substructure here we
cannot make out that there was any
structure above and as soon as we start
reducing it we're resolving with higher
and higher frequencies you can think of
it like that so if
this is let's say on the order of a
cell and then we want to get to the
order of an atom well we need to shoot
smaller and smaller wavelengths of light
this corresponds to the wavelength and
all of a sudden now you can resolve that
distance
i'm placing that as an aside here
because the way that it's ordinarily
explained is a bit confusing by the way
based on this number density you can now
get a actual density so what do you do
is you times it by the proton mass
because the proton slash the neutron are
what hold the most well the largest
contribution to the mass
and then you get the density of solids
which is the approximate density of the
earth too
see all of this which is ordinarily seen
as tremendously advanced can be
calculated extremely easily with napkin
calculations
okay now we're on the last one the
scales of the universe in particular the
higgs boson which is extremely easy now
that we've gone through plenty of these
exercises and you're so familiar with
natural units and gevs and so on what is
the scale that you should find the higgs
boson how far should you zoom in to find
it well firstly let's go on google
and we see look they give you the mass
in terms of gev now this c we set to one
so this gev it's 125 gev
125
g e v higgs
boson
from the above conversion chart or we
can go to a website and see what does
that correspond to in terms of length
now you can see how far do you have to
zoom in in order for you to find the
higgs boson you can convert that or you
can use another chart they're all
approximately the same remember we only
care about the order we can also type in
well what is the lhc
what is the highest energy of the
particles that have been collided and
it's 13 tev we covered this earlier that
tells you something concrete about how
small the distances are now these
numbers are no longer foreign to you
you're extremely familiar with
manipulating them you can get a handle
on them by the way another reason why
they're afraid that black holes could be
created well i didn't mention this in
the extra dimensions part but it's
because if gravity is leaking in to some
other dimension then that means that
gravity is in fact stronger than we
think somewhere else so it's weaker here
but it's stronger somewhere else and so
what we think of as what would
ordinarily create a black hole the
conditions may be much smaller because
gravity is much stronger than we think
though luckily the earth hasn't been
enveloped by a black hole at least not
yet
okay great you should congratulate
yourself because in about two hours or
an hour and a half however long this
video is you've now covered quite a
significant amount of work we've gone
through newton's constant and seeing
that it's actually mass dependent or
energy it's proportional to the
mass to the inverse square of a mass and
pressure and speed is dimensionless
this pressure in a neutron star the
proportionate strength of forces knots
and extra dimensions calculating the
swinger limit just getting a handle on
it the size of the earth analyzing the
sun the casimir effect how it falls off
a vacuum expectation energy the length
of an atom
microtubules
sk the higgs boson the god particle you
even learned about deriving the
schwarzschild radius and black holes and
by the way for fun these acrostically
spell out napkin calculations
all of this becomes virtually child's
play
once you use natural units and then
some physical intuition
all right now continue watching for the
next couple minutes because this will
help you contextualize what came before
and so it will stick more readily recall
unlike giving viewer exercises quote
unquote which is par for the course in
most courses and lectures and so on
people almost never do exercises
including myself and i'm extremely
motivated to do so the most nourishing
approach is to provide a point of view
shift and that's what you now have there
are a variety of phenomenon that you can
now do an nc too so a napkin calculation
and if you find a particularly inventive
one then share it in the comments
section but delineate each step don't
skip when explaining to people now as
you go through life and you want to
develop a bit more of a physical
intuition then constantly think about
what you're seeing and the numbers that
you're hearing and the lengths and the
times and the quantities etc in terms of
gev and also think about how you can
derive them from these somewhat
fundamental principles a last note on
learning every time that you hear
someone describe some object in a
different way
so for example you may hear me refer to
fields in some other video as a group
twice over and what's meant by that what
do i mean by that it's that you have
these field axioms so commutative
associative neutral elements so on so on
so on and it's it's two of them whereas
one of these is like
a group a commutative group and so it's
somewhat like a twice over group this is
this is false because there's an
interplay between these like you need to
exclude the neutral element here for the
multiplicative inverse and so on however
the point is that when you hear someone
explain something that you think you
know but explained in a different way
it's useful to write that down in some
reference document and then eventually
go back and think how are all these
disparate lessons or views the same
another one may be how are all the
exponentials the definitions of
exponentials the same so we know that an
exponential map goes from t e g so the
lead algebra to
the group itself well how is that
related to
what we know as e to the e squared for
example equals so and so on
as a number by the way almost no one
will do this exercise that is you write
down the disparate lessons and teachings
and then you try to relate them there's
about n choose two of them so how is
this related to that how is this related
to that how is this related to that how
is this related to that and so on
almost no one will do that because it's
extremely tedious which means if you do
this then you'll garner far more insight
than your peers maybe that
that
competitive edge will
tickle your rivalrous nature if it does
then you can use it as motivation and
for myself i may be doing a video at
some point i'm not don't hold me to this
on how the various definitions of
entropy are all related so there's
shannon there's thermo
there's neg entropy there's residual
entropy
and so on so on as i mentioned before
this video will be akin to an
introduction to another video that i
plan on releasing at some point now this
one has taken way way way too long so
perhaps i thought i was going to do it
in a few months this going through a
theoretical physics paper you don't
currently understand
i was going to go through geometric
unity perhaps i won't do that in a few
months perhaps it will be the winter
time now because this was way way way
more difficult than i thought it would
be regardless you can expect that at
some point so the question is is this
leading anywhere this
lecture series and i don't plan on
releasing more content like this as this
is not my forte i'm interested in what i
call explicating the landscape of
theories of everything which means to
intensely investigate each toe geometric
unity wolf rooms so there's a thumbnail
here you can click on or in the
description thomas campbells there's
theories on consciousness there's veltan
xiaowungs like
ian mcgilchrist and john verveicky i
mentioned before there's interpretations
of quantum theory like carlo revelli and
nicholas jison there's even how to go
about learning mathematics with norman
weilberger and richard borchards
i highly recommend both of their youtube
channels by the way norman in particular
is great at making whatever is complex
seems so elementary that it's criminally
humiliating
now most people have a subscriber
request but i have a request for you to
not subscribe unless you're interested
in podcasts about the above as this
channel's
bread and butter are those podcasts you
will be sorely disappointed if you
expect more videos like this so check
out some of the other podcasts on this
channel here's a playlist for you to get
started also it's linked in the
description
again if you have an interesting nc
about some napkin calculation about some
observable that ordinarily is a tedious
calculation that you can arrive at
simply from this new natural unit point
of view then make sure to leave it in
the comments and make it clear what each
step is don't skip any steps i'll also
place a thread in the subreddit
reddit.com r theories of everything and
i'll try to comment on the most
interesting ones if you want to share or
get feedback on your nc or on your
theory of everything let's imagine you
have one then or some ideas to one then
go to the discord that's also linked in
the subreddit below again like i
mentioned there's no one source on this
it's strewn generally across several
lectures and you start to intuit it as a
physics student
however
videos that served as inspiration to
this one are that of nima arkani hamed
andrew dotson
pretty much physics and sabine
hostenfelder i recommend you check out
all of those channels the links to their
work are in the description
thank you and take care
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l that is kurt jaimungle
it's support from the patrons and from
the sponsors that allow me to do this
full-time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you